okay so
tennis is now out in the uk and the film
makes the script for memento
look like the script for the power
rangers movie not that one
the 90s one now there's a lot to talk
about and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down everything
that you need to know about its plot
the order of the events and the way that
the time inversion technology in the
film works
i just want to get into it as there's a
lot to unpack but obviously there will
be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't seen it then i suggest
you watch
it when you've had the time
anyway enough of the bad jokes as always
this is the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host definition now let's get
into our breakdown of tenet
okay so before discussing the plot we
have to go over the premise of the movie
namely the time inversion that's used in
it though the film tries to dabble with
the idea of the multi-worlds theory
which was coined by david deutsch in the
end it actually subscribed to the
grandfather paradox way of thinking
this theory states that if one were to
travel back in time and kill their
grandfather
before they'd given birth to their
mother or father they would actually
find this impossible
because you wouldn't be born and
therefore couldn't travel back
and kill your own grandfather which i
don't know why you want to kill him
anyway mate
seems like a lovely guy now even though
the movie makes it seem like it could be
possible to change the past
the characters in it are actually on
predetermined paths to make sure that
everything happens the way that it's
supposed to
whether intentional or not this has
massive implications for the ending
and makes things operate in a sort of
closed loop now as for the time
inversion technology
we learned that in the future there
exists an oppenheimer-like scientist
in case you don't know robert
oppenheimer was the atomic bomb designer
and similar to the real life figure this
scientist develops world-ending
technology
through the use of radiation within
physics there exists things known as
tachyon particles
which hypothetically can travel faster
than light because of this
being inconsistent with the laws of
physics these particular particles are
able to potentially move backwards and
forwards through time the future
scientists developed a way to invert an
object's entropy
so instead of moving forward through
time like how we experience it
it actually moves backwards however
because the future relies on the past
these particles cannot change things in
the past
and they must follow the motion in which
they were put into the future
which is their past now the entropy has
several negative effects on the human
body
and bullets which are inverted deal
catastrophic damage
as it's impossible to treat wounds
caused by them due to the objects moving
backwards through time
when humans are subjected to a two they
also struggle
as instead of breathing in oxygen
they're breathing in carbon dioxide and
therefore have to don gas masks
i hope this makes sense but yeah there's
a lot of stuff to get your head around
this is basically how our protagonist is
able to fight himself from the future
moving backwards
and so on and so forth now the most
simplistic way of describing
it that i can think of is that if you
watch this video from beginning to end
you will have this film explained to you
probably better than ign did however
if you were to rip the video and then
play it backwards though the same
information would be conveyed to you
it would be reversed however if you had
your entropy inverted
it would play out the same and you would
once more see it how it was meant to be
the scientists who created it quickly
realized that this would be a weapon of
immense power
that could cause the universe to fold in
on itself if enough items were inverted
and thus she splits up an object known
as the algorithm into nine parts
and inverts them sending them back
through time however there are those in
the future that do not believe that the
past
actually has any bearing on their
present and that they would create an
alternate timeline for themselves if
they were to destroy it
because of climate change in the way
that the world is in the future
they're facing extinction and in a
last-ditch attempt to save themselves
they believe that wiping out the cause
of their misery namely us
would mean that their present is no
longer victim to the things that we
wrought onto the world
basically imagine skynet but with less
rebooted timelines
and you get the idea now though it's not
said
i believe that the reverse entropy
studies stem from trying to reverse the
effects of climate change
but they hit a brick wall and thus
assume that they could remove us in one
fell swoop
to completely mitigate the problem these
people in the future communicate with an
arms dealer known as saito
who we learn has inoperable pantriatic
cancer saito is an extremely possessive
and selfish man
and because of this he believes that if
he has to die
then the rest of the world should go
with him when sato was younger he
discovered a large metal drum in the
ruins of a destroyed city
and this was filled with several gold
bricks and also instructions which were
directed at him
for what you should do going forward now
this pretty much
outlines his plot and it becomes the
basis of the protagonist's mission
now we could sit here debating time
travel all day and tennis is smart
enough not to dwell on it for too long
but i will be putting together a more
in-depth breakdown of it later in the
week so definitely keep your eyes out
however you do need to understand the
basics of it to understand
how the movie moves forward to explain
it better we'll be using our protagonist
aptly named the protagonist to explain
how everything works
now at the beginning he's moving forward
through time and we join him as he's
about to embark on an operation to stop
a siege at an opera in kiev
here he encounters the first part of the
algorithm but the mission goes awry
and it's taken by russian forces the
protagonist is almost killed during the
op
however he's saved by a man who seems to
be moving backwards
this man has a backpack with a piece of
red string hanging out of it
which becomes very important later on
the protagonist who i'm just gonna be
calling
john from now on because hey if they
don't use his name then i might as well
use the actors
look john is captured and tortured
however he bites down on a suicide pill
showing that he's willing to sacrifice
himself john wakes up and it's revealed
that this was actually a test
to see if he was willing to put his life
on the line no matter what
and he's drafted into a secret
organization and told the word tenet
tenet is of course a palindrome which
means that it's the same forwards as it
is backwards
and it provides a way of thinking that
really needs to be on your radar
get it because radar is is the same
forward as
as it is backwards never mind look in
this organization
john learns of the inverted time objects
namely bullets which he tracks to an
arms dealer named prior
who eventually leads him to sator saito
is a closely guarded man
and jon believes that he can use the
villain's estranged wife in order to get
closer to him
and find out what's going on we discover
that saitor's wife cat
absolutely hates her husband but she
can't leave him because of a son
whom she loves dearly saito has complete
control over her life
and only allows her to meet her son for
a couple of moments at the end of school
before he's picked up by his men saito
once bought a forged painting
and should cat try to do anything he
would incriminate her for the peace
and thus she would end up in jail now
there was a time when the pair were
actually happy together
when they were on saito's boat it looked
like things were going to change
however when cat was travelling back to
the boat one day she noticed a woman
diving off it into the sea
and thus assumed that sata was having an
affair and the two drifted apart
cat explains that she will give jon a
dinner with her husband in exchange for
destroying the painting
jon recruits neil played by robert
pattinson and during the mission
he comes face to face with a swat team
member who's moving backwards through
time
inside sator's vault they discover a
time inversion machine
which the assailant and another version
of himself springs from
but he manages to escape before they can
kill him
this pretty much ruins the mission and
john lies to cat in order to gain access
to her husband
now i'm going to be jumping over the
plot points here as there's so many that
we could end up
with a video longer than the movie
itself but i absolutely adored the way
that nolan put the building blocks in
place early on
before knocking the entire house down
around you in the first hour i was a bit
unsure on what was going on
but by the end it really came together
after going completely bonkers
though it's getting a couple of meddling
reviews i actually really enjoyed the
movie
and basically if you love christopher
nolan then you're gonna lap this up now
saito tasks john with stealing plutonium
however this too is revealed to be a
part of the algorithm
and using time inversion upon himself
sato is able to capture jon
and his wife after things go badly due
to several mysterious time invasions
happening
it's revealed that saitor and his men
carried out a temporal pincer movement
in which one team moved forward whilst
the other team moved backwards
saito shoots his wife with an inverted
bullet and
in order to treat her john and neal
travel through a time inversion device
this will give them the time to save cat
and they remember that at saito's vault
there was a machine which could invert
them back to normal
the only time this will be accessible is
when the pair's past selves are carrying
out their mission to steal a painting
and thus they wait in the wings for it
to go ahead
during it jon comes face to face with
himself and we realized that he was
actually the assailant that was moving
backwards through time at the vault
like this video if you called it early
because i did
i got you nolan now at this point john
is moving alongside himself in regular
time
hiding in the shadows and observing
things it's here that he realizes that
he can't change the events that happen
judah pryor refusing to help him
alongside this
sator himself is moving backwards to
time to the day on the yacht that he
shared with his wife
in which they were both actually happy
at this time he will set off a dead man
switch
which will detonate the algorithm and
take the past with him
unbeknownst to him though jon and co are
aware of this
and with cat they invert themselves and
go back to the day that he was happiest
cat boards the boat whilst her past
version goes to the shore
and satoru ii waits for his past self to
exit it
thus he believes that he's spending time
with his past wife
when it's really the future one that's
aware of his plans
cat kills her husband kicks him
overboard and then dives off the boat
which her past self catches the real
saito likely returned home
however cats seeing this set in motion
the pair becoming estranged again
and led to the events of the movie
elsewhere sador's team go to set off the
algorithm
which i'm so glad they called it that
because youtube demonetized the b
word but look anyway you don't care they
go to set up the algorithm
and with neil on one side and john on
the other they create a temporal pincer
that stops the team neil eventually ends
up reverting back to normal
and he does this in order to try and
stop jon entering a bunker
which is booby trapped john makes it
through though and he comes face to face
with a russian
who's been ordered to set up the
algorithm he's locked out and has no way
of getting in
however he spots a down man with the
same tag in his backpack from the start
the russian team member is ordered to
kill jon but at the last second
this dead character springs back to life
through time inversion
takes the bullet and then unlocks the
gate before running backwards through
the tunnel
this allows jon to retrieve the
algorithm and he and another soldier are
saved by neil
who pulls them up through the bunker the
trio decide to split up the algorithm
and take it with them agreeing to never
meet one another again
it's here that we get probably the
movie's biggest twist and we learn that
neil is actually the character that had
the tag in his backpack
neil states that john actually recruited
him in the past and that the pair had
a long friendship together we learned
that jon actually inverted himself once
more
and travel back through time setting up
things in place that not only included
his recruitment
but also neil's position this is how
neil knew so much about the movie
and though it's a tada moment it also
comes with a bittersweet reveal
as neil says he'll invert himself once
more and hang around the area for a bit
this of course means that he'll go back
to save jon unlock the door
and take the bullet for him which will
of course lead to the character's death
so the last meeting of the pair actually
sparks off the encounter that will lead
to jon
making their meet for the first time in
the past jon continues on
tying up the loose ends including pryor
so that cat will be safe
and she gets to walk her son home from
school which ends the film
although jon will not go down in the
history books he will go
down through the history books setting
up in motion
things to make sure that armageddon is
averted
and the events that we saw in the film
continue the way that they were supposed
to
that ends the film and i hope i did a
good job of explaining it hopefully
better than ign
but if not i'm sorry now as for the film
itself
i have to say that i really really
enjoyed it it takes a while to get on
board with but
by the time the true timing version
kicks off you see how it all fits
together
really really well tennis is an
excellent film that i can see people
discussing for years and years
and though the characters such as the
protagonist do feel a bit underdeveloped
the complexities of the plot are what's
really special here
i mean they literally call the
protagonist the protagonist
now all that aside this is a must-see
movie and definitely worth going to the
cinema for
well in the uk i'm not i'm not sure
about the rest of the world however
it's great and though i wanted to give
it a 10 out of 10
just to do the crap pun tenet of ten
i think i'll settle for an eight just an
eight does that work i
i i don't know i'll shut up now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film
and if there's anything you took from it
that we didn't if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of 100 insane details that we
noticed in the batman trailer
we're also giving away a free copy of
the avengers on any console of your
choice
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of august so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on our discord
server linked in the description
or heavy swirls on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you